andrew cuomo governor of new york is
writing a book
about leadership during the covid19
pandemic
andrew cuomo whose policies are
responsible for killing thousands of
senior citizens
writing a book on how to lead during the
coronavirus which i will read
just after i finish harvey weinstein's
new book on relationships
and jeffrey dahmer's book on nutrition
does not make
a whole lot of sense american crisis
leadership lessons from the kovid 19
pandemic
is hailed by its publisher as a
remarkable portrait of leadership
during crisis and a gritty story of
gut-wrenching choices
that point the way to a safer future for
us all gut-wrenching choices like hey
should we kill all of those elderly
people or not kill them
and he i i disagreed with the choice
that cuomo made but apparently
that's just fine for the publishers
cuomo was one of the headliners of the
democratic national convention last
night cuomo genuinely was one of the
best
that they've got that does not bode very
well for the democrats in november we
will get into the best of the worst
i'm michael knowles the michael knowles
[Music]
show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday from john egan
when aoc said i have been thinking
well we know that's a lie that's a good
point i don't know
right off the top you know politicians
are supposed to be able to persuade you
but when aoc opens a statement with
i have been thinking we just know that
anything that's going to follow
is not true i also want to thank our
friends over at coastal
you know it's very difficult these days
to find a decent priced pair
of glasses but at coastal.com you can
get prescription glasses starting at
nine
dollars with free shipping and 30 day
risk-free returns
now one of my favorite part about
coastal coastal has a great selection
you're not going to find a better
selection anywhere
of glasses but one thing i really really
love about them
they have the most advanced virtual try
on technology that you will find
anywhere so you you can uh
you can move your head around you can
see how they look a lot of other
companies you know you'll
they'll have to mail it to you try them
on and you don't like them you gotta
mail it back not with coastal
uh it's it's just tremendous uh you can
you can finally see what all these
things will look like just go over there
you can even see just what shapes
look like on your face with coastal you
don't have to spend hours at the store
or hundreds of dollars go to coastal.com
you pick the frames you want
you see how they look on you on your
phone even and then you enter your
prescription details and order it's
really a really a tremendous experience
really very simple straightforward
through october 31st they're offering
our listeners the best deal
they have going anywhere which is 50 off
your first
set of glasses at coastal.com michael
get free shipping 30 day risk free
returns 50 off at coastal.com
michael only not until october 31st
c-o-a-s-t-a-l
dot com slash michael some restrictions
may apply
andrew cuomo just staring reality in the
face
and then putting up that middle finger
that's what andrew cuomo is doing by
publishing this book on leadership and
he did it throughout all of his speeches
and it wasn't just him it was all of the
democrats the key theme
to the democratic national convention
has been trying to seem like they don't
hate america
right the democrats have spent the last
six months burning the american flag
burning
america burning the country to the
ground toppling statues of george
washington
talking about what a terrible country
this is and always has been
publishing huge stories in new york
times about how america is racist and
terrible we have to overthrow the
founding
then you get to november and they say oh
gosh maybe that's not not a great way to
win an election
by running against the american flag so
the theme of the convention is we the
people
as if they gave two cares in the world
about the constitution and
the the theme has been patriotism so
andrew cuomo gets up there
and he talks about just how much he
loves america
joe biden is what i call america tough
tough in the best way
tough that is smart united disciplined
and loving joe biden can restore
the soul of america america it's america
tough
that's a good thing in this country it's
got good soul
donald trump he's chased that soul away
but we got to restore the soul of
america
restore the soul of america sounds in a
way
like make america great again doesn't it
that's
that's saying the same thing america
used to be great used to have this
wonderful quality now it's not there
anymore but we're going to bring it back
that's a very different tune than andrew
cuomo was singing
year year and a half ago when he said
explicitly
accidentally what he actually thinks
which is that america was never that
great
we're not going to make america great
again
it was never that great
we have not reached greatness
america was never that great we have not
reached greatness
we all knew that the democratic elites
felt this way
right the look at the 1619 project look
at the curricula in
schools and colleges for the last
decades
look at what they say when they're being
honest on the campaign trail
but even that crowd that was there for
andy cuomo
they cheered when when he said america
was never that great they cheered that's
what they believe
that's what the party believes and so
the the problem for the dnc right now
is their base hates the country but they
need to convince middle america
you know all those people in the center
the moderates the suburban housewives
that that they don't hate america and it
doesn't really work
so cuomo pretends to love the country
that we can play the old clips though
right
the democrats cozied up to a radical
woman her name is linda sarsour
she is an islamist she
is very opposed to
to much of what we cherish in this
country they've embraced her even the
women's march wouldn't embrace her she's
so
radical but the dnc did because they had
to
because linda sarsour explained the
central tension
of the dnc for the past couple nights
namely
this party belongs to the far left the
democratic party is not perfect
um but it is absolutely our party in
this moment
it's absolutely our party in this moment
uh something tells me
first of all what who is who is linda
sarsour referring to as we
she's not referring to democrats because
she's making a distinction between her
and the democrats
she's not referring to americans if you
have ever heard anything this woman's
ever said
you realize she doesn't identify
primarily as an american in the spirit
of 76.
she's referring to the far left i'm not
frankly i'm not even saying she's
referring to
islamists or any of that i think linda
sarsour is essentially a far leftist
she once explained that she only put the
hijab on because before she wore the
hijab she was just another white woman
in new york
which gets into a whole other discussion
about identity politics and how
arabs and middle easterners used to be
considered white but then
tried to create this separate identity
group all
all presuming that there's such a thing
as white privilege which raises the
question if there's such a thing as
white privilege
why would you try to distinguish
yourself from the white category
in any case that's a discussion for
another time i'm sure they'll be having
it at the dnc all night tonight
she's right the party belongs to
the far left so does a lot of the
country
belong to the far left at this point
okay so
the democrats can't be that honest about
it they've got to give these radicals a
little bit of air time here at the dnc
because they know their base likes that
and they're now beholden to the far
left so what do they do for the rest of
america
they just outright lie and we've got our
liar and chief over here
right back to andrew cuomo the european
virus infected the northeast while the
white house was still fixated on china
america can still rise to the occasion
we can put our differences aside and
find
commonality government can tell the
truth and can build trust
we can judge by content of character
rather than color of skin we can care
for one another
that americans can work together and
forge community
and a competent government that of
course we will wear masks
because we are smart and because i care
about you and because you care about me
of course we will socially distance
because staying away
shows how close we actually are
yes we will set up testing and tracing
and do whatever we need to do to
mobilize to win this battle because we
are america
we win wars and we are the greatest
country on the globe
and for all the pain and all the tears
our way
worked and it was beautiful
so until we get to that bit at the end
you know america is the greatest country
and all that
until we get to that that kind of
boilerplate patriotism that cuomo's been
injecting
all over the place everything he said
before that
is untrue every single thing
he opens up calling it the european
virus
talk about you know the left always hits
the right for conspiracy theories the q
people or whatever the the
the democratic party broadcast in prime
time
that the virus that we know with 100
certainty came from wuhan china
actually came from europe
now why is he saying that well because
what he's saying is
that it's racist the democrats have all
been saying this that it's racist
to refer to the virus as the china virus
you shouldn't refer to it with a
geographic location
but you can refer to it as european
well why is that because you can't be
racist against white people there's
one thing that they would say but then
when it comes to affirmative action they
count asians as white people so it's
very very confusing when you go down the
road of identity politics you don't know
where you're going to end up and it's
certainly not going to make a lot of
sense
but this is orwellian i mean just that
line we're going to stay apart
so that that we can show how close we
are being a part makes you very close
we're going to wear masks because we're
smart and smart people they always have
to wear masks yeah
yeah that's because of all that
scientific evidence you know yeah
that's what we're going to do i'm andrew
cuomo
great leader during coronavirus i don't
think so
none of it is true the worst part of it
the worst part
sort of the saddest part of his whole
oration
is that he said we we believe in the
content of your character
they don't they obviously don't he's
hearkening back to martin luther king
who says
that you know one day he hopes that his
black children can play with white kids
and they'll
they'll be judged not by the color of
their skin but by the content of their
character
right after he gets in this ridiculous
jab about the china virus and the
european virus
so that makes it ridiculous but even
consider it on a broader level john
marini has made this point before
the phrase judge on the content of one's
character
doesn't have any meaning in a culture
that doesn't have objective standards
in a culture that doesn't acknowledge
objective virtue
or the metaphysical soul or a moral
standard
or standards of behavior that we all
have to follow in that in this kind of
culture that we have
the democratic culture of do do what you
want to do and if it feels good do it
and a man can be a woman and nothing is
objective and nothing is true
and we have to deconstruct everything
and and
uh overturned statues and that in that
culture where everything's up for grabs
you can't judge someone on the content
of one's character
because that presumes a common
understanding of virtue
that does not exist that we do not have
and we don't have it
because the democrats destroyed it they
kept using
the whole infomercial that's how i'm
referring to the dnc is just a very long
infomercial
the whole infomercial was just one
one hack lesson in
cheap political rhetoric we'll get into
one specific trick that they use
that the minute you hear it you're never
going to be able to listen to this again
the minute you hear it you'll you can't
unhear it we'll get to that one second
first though got to thank our friends
over at ring you know it can be very
difficult
to keep an eye on who is outside your
house all day
whether you are home or not maybe you're
in your bedroom maybe
you're at the office maybe you're on a
beach somewhere hard to keep an eye on
your home
ring gives you protection at every
corner video doorbells let you answer
the door and check in on your home
anytime
keep an eye on your doorstep you speak
to delivery people when you can't come
to the door
with outdoor security cameras you can
check in on every part of your house
never miss a moment smart lighting
brightens up blind spots
make sure you always come home to a
brightly lit house
full home security systems give you
everything you need to protect your
family
pets and property i really trust these
guys
i've mentioned this before this is this
is my trick to my friends
is i give them ring home security kits
as a housewarming gift because
it's very helpful i care about my
friends i want them to be safe
because it makes you feel like you're
cool in the future but most importantly
from my perspective it's not that
expensive so you seem like a very cool
guy even though you haven't had to spend
a lot of money get a special offer on
the ring welcome kit when you go to
ring.com
knowles the welcome kit includes the
ring video doorbell 3 and chime pro
all you need to start building custom
security for your home today go to
ring.com
knowles that is ring dot com slash null
scanner w l e s
there's this there's this trick you hear
it i'm sure the republicans do it too
but the democrats
do it so much less convincingly
when politicians speak they they use a
construction which is this not that
so let's say like you know i like
pancakes not omelets
i like uh sunshine not rain
i like chocolate not vanilla and the
thing about it is when when a hack
politician is using this kind of
construction you always know the thing
they say they're not doing is the thing
they are doing
so just i'll give you an example just
take a listen here's dnc chairman tom
perez and then of course our liar in
chief
andrew cuomo with this precise
construction
we will work to meet our extraordinary
challenges because progress
is made by the hopeful not the cynical
and we will do that work together
because
movements are built by the many not the
few
a leader who appeals to the best within
us not the worst
a leader who can unify not divide
a leader who can bring us up not tear us
down
and of course in all of these cases the
thing they're saying they're not doing
and the things they say they are not are
the things that they are and the things
that they're doing
the the future you know the political
movement belongs to the hopeful
not the cynical it's like has there ever
been a more cynical person than tom
perez
this is built by the many not the few
the dnc is one of the most famously
oligarchic organizations in america
we need a leader who will bring us
together not divide us
name me a more divisive politician than
andrew cuomo he just said america was
never that great
come on come on folks we need someone
who's going to lift us up not bring us
down
andrew cuomo's got thousands and
thousands of senior citizens dead
because of his stupid policies
so this is what they do they're just
lying to you it's all a big lie
and i want to get into in a moment
why they think they can lie to you but
just consider how far these lies go
the democratic national convention
believed that it was a good idea
to send a member a representative
to the native american caucus the native
american working group
do you know which prominent democrat
they sent
to the native american caucus to i
you know i know that you know you know
that i know that you know
take a listen hello to the dnc native
american caucus
it is such an honor to join you all
today
liowatha herself there she is pocahontas
chief spreading bull she
this woman who had to drop out of the
presidential race
who was crippled going into the
presidential race in a way that she
never recovered from because she lied
about being native american
to get better jobs to advance in her
career she lied for decades and then it
turned out she's
the whitest woman to ever walk the earth
they sent her
as if none of that happened you remember
at the time she took a dna test
she said i might be one one thousand
twenty fourth native american
she published this she sent this to the
boston globe as though that exonerated
her
that's how divorced from reality they
are that's how much they think they can
hoodwink you
and they're doing it again doesn't
matter
now part of the reason they sent liz
warren in the democrats defenses who
else are they going to get
namely a prominent native american
democratic
politician at the national level can you
name me one
no of course not and and frankly
the whole democratic left-wing argument
on native americans is they're a
separate country it's their land they
shouldn't participate
in colonial american politics so they're
setting themselves up from the beginning
not to have any prominent
native american politicians also when
you divvy up the electorate and you make
your entire
base your whole coalition just about
ever more narrow
identity victim groups well then you
have egg on your face when you don't
have a representative for that victim
group
i mean you know the victim groups divide
and divide and divide there's no
end to that so eventually they're going
to run out of people to represent them
they seem already to have done that
that's why they had to send liz warren
and then maybe i don't know maybe the
most egregious lie
the most patently absurd one
came from a little bit of a blast from
the past
bill clinton the first president that i
remember you know going back to
some of our childhoods came out to
lecture
president trump bill clinton who just
had photos released yesterday
of him receiving a neck massage from one
of jeffrey epstein's sex slaves
bill clinton has a bit of a colorful
history when it comes to his personal
behavior
went out and lectured donald trump about
how to comport himself in the oval
office
at a time like this the oval office
should be a command center
instead it's a storm center there's only
chaos
just one thing never changes his
determination to deny responsibility
and shift the blame the buck never stops
there and let me tell you something if
somebody knows about bucking in the oval
office it's
me okay i know a thing or two i never
wanted to stop bucking in the open all
right that's enough that's enough of
that
we all know that bill clinton got up to
no good in the oval office
this was kind of the news story of the
1990s when i think of
coming into watching the news you know
for the first time following politics
bill clinton's personal behavior in the
oval office
would probably be at the top of the list
but he can do it just like he did in the
90s remember he came on tv in the 90s
i did not have sexual relations with
that woman
and then like five minutes later he has
to go back on tv
stare at the same tv camera goes all
right i might have had some sexual
relations with that woman
sorry whoops believe me now though
believe me i feel your pain
that's what he always did the clintons
probably the most famous
shameless liars in the country and they
defined the democratic party for decades
but is it still their party they've kept
the lying they've kept the dishonesty
they've kept the shame
shamelessness but why did they put bill
clinton up there
what were they thinking does bill
clinton
really define the democratic party
anymore probably not they may have
wanted to have a voice of relative
moderation
it's unbelievable when you think of bill
clinton's personal behavior that he is a
voice of moderation but he is in today's
democratic party which has shifted
so far to the left it is certainly no
longer the party of bill clinton
uh the the dnc probably hasn't caught up
with that and they're trying to cobble
together
this coalition of people who all share a
similar kind of ideology but they're
they're in such
disparate groups that the democratic
strategy being division
they do have a hard time holding their
coalition together
the democrats feel they can lie because
no one holds them to account that's why
i'm not just talking party at party sure
the republican party is going to call
them out
shows such as this one are going to call
out the lies and and point out what
they're saying that just isn't true
but more broadly in the culture they're
not going to get called out by hollywood
hollywood rewrites their stories for
them speaking of bill clinton you ever
see the movie the american president
by aaron sorkin it it takes the story of
bill clinton
a degenerate adulterer who doesn't
believe a damn thing
who blows in the wind and all he wants
is vanity and power
bill clinton turns him into the most
wonderful
man caring unfairly targeted by the
right
rewrites aspects of his bible he doesn't
cheat on anybody he's a widower all
these kind of things to make him
seem sympathetic obviously the press
are behind him lower education higher
education big tech everybody
big tech seemed like they were
suppressing that photo bill clinton
yesterday until it got so ridiculous
they had to let it come up on social
media
they lie because there is
there is no institution in this country
that holds them to account
with any success the one chance we have
is occasionally republicans win
elections
very rarely that matters so that they
can do things in there
and sometimes a conservative commentator
will get a word out before the sensors
come in but that's it
and so they're going to lie to you and
they're going to gaslight you
i mentioned earlier that the phrase
content of your character doesn't have
any meaning
in in this culture part of that is
because we don't have an objective
standard of virtue part of that is we
don't have an objective standard
of communication we're not speaking the
same language
we're not refer when you communicate
with somebody
that presumes that there is objective
truth outside of the two of you
and that you are using words and letters
and symbols to refer to that objective
truth
so even though you might have different
perspectives you're still at least
talking about the same thing
so you can have a conversation the
democrats
aren't doing that at a philosophical
level they don't believe in that they
don't believe in objective truth
they believe in your truth and my truth
they believe in
in forcing your vision of america
through tyranny of the will they believe
in intersectionality
where the only the only reality is my
lived experience and my oppression
that's why you always hear them say
you can't talk about that that's my
experience you can't erase my lived
experience
you can't describe the black experience
in america if you're white
now for some reason we the democrats can
explain everyone's experience
but in that in that framework there's no
conversation to be had
there's no good faith debate to be had
this is a brutal battle of
interests we talked yesterday about ways
the left is trying to steal the election
that's what it's going to come down to
this is much less
a fine debate in your garden or a
a gentlemanly election than it is
a bare-knuckle brawl that's what the
democrats were signaling yesterday
at the dnc but it goes beyond the
political arrangement it goes into
corporate america we'll get to that in
one second first i've got to thank our
friends over at pure talk
you know people think that their cell
phone bill just has to cost what it
costs
they're always gonna have to pay a lot
of money that's not true
there are easy savings that you can find
who is your wireless provider
is it att verizon t-mobile what if i
told you
pure talk usa uses the exact same
network as one of those carriers
same towers same exact coverage but it
costs you
half i i i know that you think what i'm
saying is it's a similar network it's
similar
it's the exact same one but it costs you
half switching is very easy you can keep
your phone they'll send you a new sim
card
so you can get the same great service
you currently have but at half the price
listen is unlimited talk text and two
gigs of data for just 20 bucks a month
that is insane the average person is
saving 400
a year customer service by the way is
right here in the u.s and their ceo is a
u.s veteran
who understands what it means to serve
this country head on over these guys are
the real deal unlimited talk unlimited
text
two gigs of data for just 20 bucks a
month all you need to do is grab your
mobile phone dial pound 250
say keyword michael knowles that's pound
two five zero
say k word michael knowles and when you
do you will have
fifty percent off your first month
beyond the political realm beyond the
dnc which i can't believe i've got to
watch for another
night tonight what i do for you people
what i do the sacrifices i make
look into corporate america this leaked
yesterday was a slide from a goodyear
tires
employee presentation it described their
zero tolerance policy there's zero
tolerance policy on
expression things you can say things you
can wear
here is what the slide lists as
acceptable
expression black lives matter
or lesbian gay bisexual transgender
pride
those are the two things listed under
acceptable here's what's listed as
unacceptable
blue lives matter all lives matter
mega attire or politically affiliated
slogans or material
so far left wing activism
good acceptable
anything even remotely patriotic
or conservative unacceptable
that's corporate america i mean just
these
blue you can't say that you support cops
you can't say you support law and order
that's no longer allowed because of
goodyear you can't say you
support all lives it has to be only
black lives not all lives black lives
white lives are bad hispanic lives are
bad
asian lives are very very bad no one
cares about that they don't matter
only only black lives according to
goodyear
magga you can't support the president
you can't even support the expression
make america great again you got to make
america worse
or you got to say america was never that
great just like andy cuomo said when he
was being
slightly more honest and nothing
political unless it's
left-wing i think conservatives are
finally waking up to something that they
did not understand for decades for
decades
conservatives in the republican party
carried water for corporate america
they shilled for giant transnational
corporations
with no loyalty to their own country
no sense of honor or virtue they they
bought into this
bs kind of
silly ein rand argument from the 1980s
that all that matters is money and we've
got to worship money
and any sense of solidarity as our
country any sense of respect
for our founding ideals and our founding
fathers and for the common good
is somehow un-american go back and read
the founding fathers go back and read
the writings of john adams thomas
jefferson
go back and george washington go james
madison go i mean we can list all the
founders
go read abraham lincoln do you know what
they refer to all the time
the common good virtue
loyalty patriotism solidarity with our
fellow citizens
when you go back and read the founding
fathers it doesn't read like an iran
novel doesn't read
like some bad russian novelist
okay we've got to come back to a sense
of what this country is
that doesn't mean we have to throw out
capitalism that doesn't mean we have to
hate businesses all of a sudden
but it does mean that we've got to get
our priorities in order
we are americans we have to love our
country we have to
we have a right we the people to assert
ourselves in politics
and if you're not going to do that in
your corporation
i don't want anything to do with you
okay goodyear by the way has not
confirmed that this was them
they haven't denied it either seems to
me like if this
weren't their slide they would have
denied it right away
on this point i think there are some
people there there have been some kind
of more libertarian republicans who are
afraid that the moment we start talking
about patriotism
or the common good or national borders
or anything like that
that we're going to throw capitalism out
the window but actually the opposite is
true
the the thing that is most imperiled
capitalism
private property is our lack of
patriotism
our lack of a sense of the common good
our lack of going back to our founding
fathers
that is imperiling it the democrats are
telling that to you
not just in private conversations dnc
panelists are explaining
to the youth council of the democratic
national committee committee
that they want to throw away capitalism
ditching capitalism ditching private
property goes hand in hand with ditching
a sense
of our common good and our common
tradition and our common
uh political founding we'll get to that
in one second then i got to tell you
the greatest news of all the oh my gosh
what great political news we'll get to
that one second first though
gotta thank you all for subscribing to
the michael knowles show youtube channel
we just crossed 180 000 subscribers we
will have some great content coming out
this weekend
not going to tell you what yet but it
should be fun we have a backstage this
friday
we're going to be talking about the dnc
uh the
obviously that's all we're going to be
talking about this week they're giving
us a whole lot to work with here also
you got to get all access
all access members get to join all
access live tomorrow night
august 20th we'll be doing a very
special live stream
watch party covering the democratic
national convention's biggest speakers
daily wire zone matt walsh will be
hosting it the stream starts at 8 45
eastern 5 45 pacific do not miss this
great opportunity
head on over dailywire.com you get 20
off all access
with not just one but two leftist years
tumblers with coupon code access
dailywire.com slash knowles
coupon code access get 20 off your
membership we'll be right back with a
lot more
the democrats want to destroy capitalism
democrats used to mock republicans for
saying things like that as hysterical or
some crazy fever dream no now they're
just saying it outright
at this youth council of the democratic
national committee which is all being
live streamed now
ashley macrae insisted that quote the
future we all want
that we're trying to build involves the
destruction of capitalism
and a lot of other things we understand
that
this future that we all want that we're
all trying to build
um really is about the destruction of
colonization
white supremacy and capitalism
we must we must really move away from
these
systems and these frameworks if we
really want to
live in a future that does have a
regenerative economy
and um does enable liberation and equity
for our communities
this is definitely something that we all
want to push forward and so
our hope and our our dream is that we do
push forward green new dill
blah blah blah and then they list all
the other nonsense they want
what does that mean well first of all it
shows us that the green new deal really
is about destroying capitalism right
because
she just admitted that there again aoc
denied this when when we pointed it out
when she first proposed the green new
deal
capitalism is the key here it's the key
into understanding what they mean
because she says
we want to get rid of colonization and
white supremacy and capitalism
now i think some people who aren't
paying very close attention they say
well okay i don't i don't particularly
care for colonization
yeah i certainly don't like white
supremacy so yeah let's
let's get rid of those capitalism well
see the capitalism is the key here
there is no american colonization we are
not colonizing places
where where are our colonies last colony
we have is puerto rico we didn't even
want that we still don't want that
i'd be happy to give that back to spain
so that democrats don't make it a state
and steal the senate
there's no american colonization what
they mean by colonization is america
itself
they refer to this as occupied land all
the time
they say america stole the land which
isn't true they say that uh
america has no right to be on this land
also not true
and we need to give the land back to who
i don't know give it back to the
comanche or the comanche going to give
it back to the apache that they stole it
from i don't know
i don't know that's their line they
when they say we're anti-colonization
what they mean is they're anti-the
american nation-state
you hear democrats sometimes say make
make america mexico again talking about
the land that used to be spanish
that we then took the land that maybe
they used to be french that we then
bought who knows
they're referring to the borders of our
country american sovereignty when they
say we don't want colonization what they
mean is we want open borders
and no american right to rule and to
totally overturn the idea that we the
people have the right to rule ourselves
in this country
what about white supremacy what do they
mean by white supremacy well according
to
the left everything is white supremacist
according to
you've you've just seen this come out
from major left-wing institutions
the idea that now western art is white
supremacist
the idea that western literature is
white supremacist shakespeare's white
supremacists you got to decolonize the
english departments
according to campaigns at major american
universities there's that word again
colonization
according to the left in recent days
critical thinking is white supremacist
grammar is white supremacist they've
been releasing
flyers about this sort of thing what
they're referring to is
our civilization which is not
exclusively white right western
civilization the only civilization in
the world
that hasn't defined itself primarily
racially
i don't think that eastern civilizations
are particularly
multicultural but the the the west has
embraced multiculturalism
in its kind of desiccated modern form
for many decades now
and in a truer form from the very
beginning because there is neither
jew nor greek nor bond nor free but all
are one in christ jesus
they want to get rid of that that's what
they're taught to them that's what they
mean by white supremacy
sean king a blm activist said it the
other day said yeah we got to smash
statues of jesus because it's because
it's white supremacy
so that's what they're talking about
here they want to destroy the american
nation state they want to destroy
christian christendom western
civilization call it what you want
and they want to destroy capitalism by
capitalism they mean
private property rights that's always
what that's what they're referring to
what is capitalism
capitalism the word is frankly a sort of
marxist creation
but what it's referring to in this broad
sense they're using it as
is private property they want to take
your property away
now that's not a great pitch to the
american people is it probably not
you see this reflected in some of the
poll numbers incredibly joe biden's poll
numbers are going down
even during a convention the whole point
of the convention is so your poll
numbers go up
so that's not good but i've got a a
secret poll number
see a secret data point that i i haven't
mentioned before on this show
but i got it from my publisher you know
that a few years ago three years ago now
i did this blank book called reasons to
vote for democrats a comprehensive guide
this was initially blurbed by our own
ben shapiro who referred to it as
thorough
it was then blurbed by the president of
the united states who referred to it as
a great book for your reading enjoyment
i spent my whole life researching this
book it's got an extensive bibliography
and then it's got completely blank pages
that's the thesis of the book
i sold a lot of copies when this thing
came out a lot a lot of copies and then
you know it kind of tapers off i still
sell a lot of copies of that book
because the democrats keep doing crazy
things so i usually sell about
100 200 copies a week do you know how
many copies of this book sold last week
over 3 100 copies
which is a high number even for a brand
new book that's selling well
two weeks before that what over 2200
over 2300
the book is selling we're not really
promoting this thing we're not running
ads really or anything like that
do you know who's selling this book for
me andrew cuomo
and aoc and elizabeth warren and tom
perez and the democratic national
convention
that's what's selling this book and the
joe biden campaign
that's what's selling this book
because you can order the book secretly
right just order it on amazon it comes
maybe give it to a friend or something
like that
i'm very skeptical of the polls going
into this election
because if you got a phone call right
now from some stranger and said hey
are you a a white supremacist
bigot nazi who's voting for
orange hitler and mango mussolini
are you going to tell them yes or no
some people are going to say yeah sure
yeah i am i don't care any
any of the nonsense you're saying
doesn't bother me i'm voting for trump
a lot of people are going to be cow
they're going to be quiet about it if at
goodyear
you are at risk of losing your job if
you wear anything even vaguely
supportive of the president or say
anything even vaguely supportive of the
president you're probably going to keep
your mouth shut
right but what about the only poll that
counts
in november i think i mean i use the
book kind of as
a funny example of this but i think
there are hidden data points here
that show you where the country is
really really moving i don't think the
democrats are helping themselves
at all during this dnc and so in order
to reach across the aisle
in order to try to grab some of those
moderates some of those suburban
housewives
they had a handful of squishy
republicans
some of whom most of whom no one even
remembers
and they came out to endorse at the dnc
is it because you've got to ask yourself
has trump lost any votes trump
won in 2016 no one thought he was going
to win and a lot of people were
skeptical of him then
he's done a great job since then he's
assuaged a lot of fears the never
never trump movement has completely
collapsed so
who do you lose what people are saying
is it's the suburban housewives
so you want to appeal to these more
middle-of-the-road republicans
did the democrats succeed at that let's
take a listen first up meg whitman
former ceo of hp who ran unsuccessfully
for some political offices
a woman that basically nobody remembers
at this point
here is meg whitman's message to the
convention
i'm meg whitman i'm a long-time
republican and a long-time ceo
and let me tell you donald trump has no
clue how to run a business
let alone an economy okay if donald
trump has no clue how to run a business
or an economy
how come we've all heard of him we all
know him he's the most powerful man in
the world
and very few people remember you
if he last time i checked the trump
organization
is doing better these days is much more
prominent in the public imagination
than hewlett-packard that you
the company you used to run and i think
she runs another one i don't even know
the name of this company that she
currently runs
she's a lifelong republican what are her
positions i just did a quick little
google search
she's a lifelong staunch republican
who's in favor of
open borders who's against marriage and
who's pro-abortion
that's it they got us wow principled
conservatism
oh my god donald trump he's a fake
conservative not like the real
conservatives like
open borders anti-marriage pro-abortion
meg whitman right how about the next one
another whitman coincidentally
christine todd whitman former governor
of new jersey a thousand years ago
here's christine todd whitman's
invective against president trump i'm
governor christine todd whitman
what am i doing here i'm a lifelong
republican my parents were introduced at
a republican national convention by
their parents that's how far back it
goes
but this isn't about a republican or
democrat it's about a person
a person decent enough stable enough
strong enough to get our economy back on
track a person who can work with
everyone
democrats and republicans to get things
done
donald trump isn't that person joe biden
is
joe biden as principal conservative i've
been a republican so long my
grandparents were republicans and they
introduced my my parents who are
republicans and
okay let's take a look at her record oh
yeah against marriage pro-abortion
and pro-partial birth abortion this
monster this this woman
supports a policy that would allow you
to
partially give birth and then kill the
infant
in 1999 whitman when she was when she
was governor
vetoed a bill that outlawed partial
birth abortion
that's that rock-ribbed conservative so
if you're a republican who's going to
vote for joe biden
you're siding with those principled
conservatives like the ones who support
partial birth abortion and then then my
favorite
then the best we had been waiting we
knew this moment was going to come
john kasich junk whose father was a
mailman if in case you had forgotten
john kasich
comes out he was a somewhat prominent
2016 contender for president on the
republican side
he endorses joe biden because america
is at a crossroads take a listen america
is at a crossroads
sometimes elections represent a real
choice a choice we make as individuals
and as a nation about which path we want
to take when we've come to challenging
times
america is at that crossroads today
he's standing at a crossroads
[Laughter]
no this is so lame this is
somehow even lamer than john kasich if
you just took john kasich by himself
that would be very lame
but john kasich referring to crossroads
while standing at a crossroad
that is like the lamest thing i've ever
seen i was waiting for him to say
america's come to a fork in the road and
then he lifts up a dining fork
or he just got there and he just started
he just started turning himself around
like spinning around america's at a
turning point
you know it's not not very convincing
and what is he talking about
you know i'm not going to subject you to
listening to the rest of his ridiculous
uh oration but none of these people
ever get to issues all it boils down to
is donald trump was mean to me
and joe biden was nice to me and it's
all about
me me me it's all about personal
behavior and it's all about the tweets
because for these people even kasich
kasich is the worst one because kasich
actually had a pretty good record
in his early political career but
somewhere along the way he got to
get to a fork in the road and he took he
took the wrong path
you know what happens at crossroads by
the way i don't know if any of you are
blues
music aficionados bad things happen at
crossroads
you know people meet that people tend to
meet the devil at crossroads okay
and that would that would seem to be
what's happening here
because for these people i mean maybe
john kasich used to be about something
real certainly hasn't been in quite a
long time
politics is not about changing anything
politics is not about
supporting our cherished institutions
politics is not about rolling back
this awful tide of leftism it's not
about pushing back against this
anti-constitutional administrative
bureaucracy that's taking our political
power away from
we the people it's just about
going along to get along it's just about
being
the governor being the congressman being
the president it's not about doing
anything
there are some people who have the
audacity to refer to themselves as
principled conservatives
who are siding with these hacks because
they say trump's not a real conservative
trump is the most conservative
politician of my lifetime
not in any traditional you know not not
in any you know past 30 40 years since
not in his comportment even in many ways
but in what he's doing in his political
vision
much more conservative than any of these
hacks
very sad to see kasich go like this i
don't think they're going to convince
anybody though
i don't think they're going to get get
anybody to actually go over
because christine todd whitman told them
to
so all they've got now are these lies
they they drag these people in front and
say i'm a lifelong rock ribbed
republican
not true they'll have andrew cuomo come
out there and say we love america
we support america we did a great job
during the covig crisis they're going to
push these lies on you just like they've
been pushing a lot of lies especially
for the last five months
the only question of this election is
going to be do we let them get away with
it
i don't think this election is going to
be about persuading people or convincing
anybody which is what elections should
be about
i think this is going to be a bare
knuckle brawl over tactics
one can they hoodwink you because they
own the
the mainstream media because they own
the app the apparatuses and the
institutions
and then are they gonna be able to steal
it at the mailbox which is which is
the big political operation that's
currently underway
are you gonna let them do it or not i
hope that the rnc
goes out does a live convention or at
least a partially live convention it
might be too late for that but they
should
this infomercial dnc thing is such trash
it's so pathetic
that if we went out there showed a
little life i think that could rev up
the base but then on the operational
front
you got to make sure that you don't let
what what drew clavin would call the
empire of lies
you don't let this this desiccated
dishonest edifice that gaslights you at
every turn
get power again because if they're
shameless now when they're
sort of out of power imagine what it'll
be
if they take power back again in
november that's our show i'm michael
noel's the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies
executive producer jeremy bourie
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
technical producer
austin stevens assistant director pavel
wadowski
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico
audio mixer robin fenderson hair and
makeup
nika geneva production assistant ryan
love
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
20 20. if you prefer facts over feelings
aren't offended by the brutal truth and
you can still laugh at the insanity
filling our national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
see you there